we begin in the middle east where both
israeli forces and palestinian militants
have stepped up their attacks in the
worst fighting scene
in years the u.n now warning of the risk
of full-scale war
and here's a look at the intensity of
the violence an entire tower block
flattened by israeli airstrikes in gaza
at least 35 people have been killed
there
and israel says hamas has fired more
than a
thousand rockets since monday killing at
least five israelis the u.n security
council
is set to hold an urgent meeting on
wednesday over the unrest
[Music]
sirens fill the night sky over tel aviv
from their rooftops terrified residents
watched the missiles descend on their
city
israel's famed iron dome defense system
overwhelmed by the sheer
number of rockets launched by hummus
from gaza
israel's prime minister pledged revenge
hamas and islamic jihad have paid and i
tell you
they will pay a very heavy price for
their aggression
i say here tonight their blood beyond
their heads
[Music]
israeli airstrikes have been pounding
gaza here a building housing hamas
officials is felled by israeli bombs
neither side is willing to back down
if israel wants to escalate we're ready
for it and if it wants to stop we're
also ready
if they want to remove their hand over
jerusalem we're ready
despite israel's sophisticated defenses
hamas's primitive missiles are more than
a mere nuisance
they've taken lives and destroyed
property but israeli airstrikes have
extracted a much heavier toll on gaza's
population
a final goodbye as these relatives bury
their loved ones
the us has taken the lead in calling for
a peaceful resolution to the crisis
we are deeply concerned about the
escalation between israel
and those launching rockets from gaza
and we call for
restraint and for calm israel has the
right to defend itself
and to respond to rocket attacks the
palestinian people
also have the right to safety and
security
but in such a tense situation the right
to safety and security for all sides
remains an elusive goal
let's cross straight over to our
jerusalem correspondent tanya kramer
tanya tell us more about those israeli
airstrikes in gaza and the rocket
attacks on israel
what's been happening though well as
we've seen in the report it has been
definitely a very
uh difficult night for the residents in
gaza but also for the israeli residents
under
you know the rocket attacks now uh there
has been a very
dense uh air bombardment from the
israeli military overnight and
especially also in the early morning
hours
on gaza we understand that two
residential high-rise buildings in gaza
were targeted but also many
institutional buildings like police
stations in gaza were damaged or
destroyed the destruction there is still
assessed according to local sources in
gaza
at the same time you've seen since last
night also a major escalation by hamas
and the islamic jihad by launching
rockets towards
the center of israel including
tel aviv according to the israeli army
over a thousand
thousand rockets have been launched
towards israel and the army says
they have targeted over 500 sites
in the past day and a half
of these hostilities but of course those
numbers are changing
by the minute now tanya there's also
growing tension between
arab israelis and jews on the ground
in israel how serious is that
well that's right uh we've seen already
a lot of protests here in the past
uh weeks uh in in uh mixed
cities or specially at towns with an
arab israeli or our palestinian
communities over the issues related to
east jerusalem namely the pending
eviction
of palestinian families in a palestinian
neighborhood in east jerusalem
but the particular focus right now is on
the city of
lude where we've seen a lot of violence
between
some members of the arab community there
and israeli police
and also between residents of the of
the two communities living in the city
and that has been fueled by the shooting
of a young
man on monday night from the arab
community by a jewish
resident president the israeli prime
minister
benjamin netanyahu has now declared the
city
in a state of emergency and has ordered
reinforcements
in the city to restore calm as he said
okay well with all that happening the
u.n
as we mentioned is warning a full-scale
war
could break out what efforts are being
made to prevent that
well we've heard a lot of statements now
also by
the united nations and the international
community
calling for the de-escalation it is
unclear at the moment
uh whether you know both sides have an
interest now
at this particular time uh to
de-escalate
what happens usually what we've seen in
previous round at least behind the
scenes mediation efforts
are usually going on between
brokered by actors like egypt qatar
and the united nations and others trying
to mediate between the militant factions
in gaza
and israel but at the moment you know
it's not clear
whether this is happening uh um and what
kind of political maneuvering what space
is there
to end those hostilities at that
particular point now in time
tanya thank you that was dw's tanya
kramer in jerusalem
you